pero creo que en este caso está digamos
disparado este este decreto de
emergencia por la situación que se dio
recientemente en ecuador con casi dos
centenas de muertos en las cárceles y
esto es atribuido por todos los
analistas y todos los especialistas en
el tema al avance del narcotráfico en el
país y hay que diferenciarlo hay que
diferenciar la inseguridad que viene del
narcotráfico de la inseguridad digamos
de los delitos menores como son robos de
teléfonos celulares en fin creo que esto
va sobre todo dirigido a la primera al
al narcotráfico bueno de otra parte es
un estado de excepción la mejor manera
para teclear a los problemas
precisamente del narcotráfico en el país
que tanto cabe en este caso por ejemplo
la discusión de la ilegalidad que es
finalmente lo que provoca el ambiente de
crimen alrededor de los estupefacientes
y precisamente iba a referirme a eso la
pregunta es muy apropiada porque el
problema del narcotráfico es un problema
integral no es un problema solamente de
controlar armas en las calles es un
problema que tiene que ver con
verdaderas mafias organizadas por lo
tanto rebasa incluso las fronteras de un
país es un problema multinacional y hay
que enfocarlo desde esa perspectiva es
de ser multidimensional también y creo
que el decreto de emergencia además
debido a las disposiciones legales y
constitucionales de ecuador tiene un
alcance limitado en términos de tiempo
por lo tanto pasará esto y podríamos
volver a la misma situación y finalmente
el presidente lanzó denunció que ecuador
o pasó de ser un país productor a ser
también un país consumidor porque para
usted esta evolución del problema y que
tanto empeora la situación
una una de las causas es que a los
las mafias de traficantes tienen redes
muy
y nutridas digamos en cada uno de los
países y gran parte del pago que hacen
ellos a las redes las hacen en especie
digamos es decir en droga por lo tanto
estas estos integrantes de las redes
tienen que vender la droga en el país no
pueden sacarla ya las sacan sus jefes
digamos y ellos no tienen la capacidad
logística para exportarla y tienen que
venderla internamente entonces
evidentemente eso incrementa el consumo
interno